Now queries in monodb are based on the document model
as well. In order to find items of interest, we
want to specify a document that resembles those we're looking
for. So let's take a look at an example with
the autos data set. If we want to find all
autos that have a manufacturer of Toyota We construct a
query document like this. The general principle here is that
we construct the query document, having the fields and values for
those fields that we'd like to see in every document
in our results set. One additional thing I'll point out
here is, that we're simply looping through our results and
printing out each one of them. Okay let's run this.
Okay, so we can see that in the documents
we got back, we have a manufacturer value of Toyota.
And if we were to scroll through this entire result
set, we'd see that all of them in fact do.